mais rodez où est mort cette nuit à 92
ans c'est un peu le ciel qui nous tombe
sur la tête comme dans les albums
d'astérix
uderzo c'était avant tout un personnage
timide mais en même temps l'un des
grands géants l'un des derniers géants
de la bd franco belge qui vient de
disparaître
ces ponts à leonardo peut s'apercevoir
maintenant en relisant tous les astérix
qu' il ya une fluidité incroyable dans
la façon dont il dessine
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas le rôle facile parce que
autant moi je mène même rené goscinny au
dixième album se disait que les mêmes
cet effet c'était le tour de gaule et il
m'avait dit tu sais j'ai l'impression
que on a tout dit sur les gaulois pour
trouver une nouvelle idée on va avoir du
mal et il a trouvé encore 14 titres si
l'on a fait 24
[Musique]
oh
le